Is it possible to make a
Billboard #1 song in 30 seconds?
Recently people have started
speedrunning hit songs,
where you compete to see who can
recreate the beat the fastest.
One of the most popular challenges
is Soulja Boy’s Crank That from 2007.
First people started bragging about
recreating the beat in 2 minutes,
then 1 minute, then… 33.76 seconds.
The practice of speedrunning
comes from video games,
and it’s not a coincidence that people
have started speedrunning Crank That.
“Crank That” was created
on the software FL Studio,
and the developer behind FL Studio
was actually a video game developer.
Didier Dambrin is the award-winning game
developer that created FL studio in 1997.
FL Studio is known for being really easy to use,
Dambrin himself calls it “an app for cheaters.”
So these days, just like speedrunning a video
game, producers can make beats faster than ever.